- If I can say anything
for the whole crew here
never do anything other
than what you think you
should do music-wise.
Based on my thesis that
hip hop rules the world,
it's probably a $50 billion company--
("Disrespectful" by Gashi)
- Yeah man, thanks for
having us, this is great.
- My pleasure, man.
- This office is sick.
- Thank you bro.
How you doing Boyd?
- We're good, man.
We were just talking about
the album listening forward
and going around and meeting fans.
- How's it going?
- Yeah, we've been surprising
fans just at their houses.
It's awesome dude, just to
see their reactions in person.
- People shit.
- Create that relationship, you know?
- Depth over width.
- Yeah, yeah.
- We were talking a little bit
about the Logic video that you did.
- Yeah done with (mumbles).
- Yeah I knew that.
Thank you.
- So I was checking up on all the content
but that one obviously stood out to me
and I was just saying Babbin is alright,
he's such a charismatic guy
and such a hard worker.
So I was really interested
in hearing you guys talk
'cause he's already so,
such a driven dude you know,
like such an entrepreneur in that sense.
- You know what it is?
It's like fucking, I've been
thinking about this so much,
it's like chips on shoulders.
There's something very obvious to me
that the internet's doing.
It's flipping the world, right?
Like I think so much of what's
happening in our society,
like people are trying to,
there's a lot going on, right?
I don't think people understand
how big of a deal it is.
It's much bigger than people think.
I genuinely believe
that what the internet's doing right now
gives the disproportionate advantage
to the people that start off at the bottom
because the cost of entry
used to be blocked by
the people at the top
but now the internet is the game.
- Yeah it's the gateway to--
- Like your world.
MTV had say,
Hot 97 had say,
Casey Kasem, Dick Clark, Soul Train, TV.
SoundCloud has say now.
If I want to be humongous,
I'd go to SoundCloud
and go put a song up.
- Seriously that's how I got my following.
It's a free platform.
Yeah why not?
- SoundCloud, Spotify,
Facebook, YouTube, Instagram,
game over.
All the leverage.
The only people that will have leverage
are the person that
makes it and the audience
and the way it used to be
was everybody in the middle took pieces.
The end.
- Yeah no, you're totally
right, it's crazy.
- It's crazy.
I think a lot about Prince,
how he had so many things right
and so many things wrong.
In his ethos, he understood
but he demonized the internet
'cause it was taking his
money in the short term
but it was actually exactly
what he gave a fuck about.
I think about that a lot
where like it's like the fine line.
Like you know what I'm
always interested in?
The fine line between
confidence and delusion.
- Interesting.
- I think delusion's scary,
it's why people lose.
My son yesterday goes,
daddy, I'm gonna dunk when I'm older.
I'm like my man, you're not gonna dunk.
I go you will never dunk.
And he goes why?
I'm like, DNA.
And it was interesting moment.
I just said in the last podcast,
I've been thinking about it all day,
and I was so happy
because I think I did so right by my son.
So many parents don't do that.
They're like yes you
will, game over, delusion.
Meanwhile, can he be a
remarkable basketball player?
Of course he can.
I'm teaching him Euro step
lefty layups right now,
that's all he's doing.
He's literally over and over,
lefty layups Euro stepping.
Like you could dominate
some YMCA games in 20 years.
So thinking a lot about that.
- Yeah that's interesting.
Not feeding into false hope in a way.
- Right 'cause I'm putting out content
and I'm like yo, you can do it,
put out your music, put it out, volume.
The problem is you also
have to have talent.
But a lot of kids on the other side,
they hear, like yo, I'm
gonna be huge, that's me
but no it's not
because you didn't deploy self awareness
or you didn't grow up in an environment
where you weren't taught delusion.
And the flip side, you have the other side
where parents make kids insecure
because they were insecure
and misery loves company
and your sad so you're
telling your kid you suck.
Got it?
And so that middle.
Want to know why I'm happening?
The middle.
If you really want to
understand my content
and my message,
I'm like yo, let's go.
I believe that every
person I'm looking at,
and some people I know and
some I don't, can do anything
until you show me that you can't.
And that's, you know?
- Yeah, crazy concept,
but it's true though.
- It's such a fun,
well it's funny, I read my
comments on my content, right,
you get feedback
and literally if you read it,
in the same post
people are saying completely
the opposite thing.
So like yo, Gary Vee, your
shit it's so fucking straight,
this is what I love about you,
you don't fucking sugar
coat it, you fucking give it
and literally the next comment's like,
yo, this is what's fucked up,
all you're saying is it's all good,
it's not fucking good.
I'm like, they're literally
contradicting themselves
in the same post.
And it's like oh 'cause I'm
sitting it right in the middle,
the person's exposing
where they're mind's at
on how they consume it.
- Mmhmm, interesting, damn.
I don't know how to follow that up
but yeah that's crazy man.
- Can I tell you how you follow it up?
If I can say anything
for the whole crew here,
never do anything
other than what you think
you should do music wise.
People get stupider,
people get talked out
of what gets you there.
- Totally.
It almost took me out of this last album
because I got in my head
finally for the first time
because a couple people at the label
started to disagree with
some choices I made musically
and they just wanted me to
work more on the project
and it was like the
minute I was doing that,
I was second guessing the
reason I got to this point.
I was questioning decisions I was making
but those same decisions I made
were the reason I had the
record deal in the first place.
- Brother, I love you
so much for saying this.
I say this all the time,
I'm like yo, why the fuck
did you even get here
and now you think you have
to do something, right?
And the problem is, especially in hip hop,
actually it's not true, in country,
actually what the fuck am
I talking about, in music,
one of the things that's very tough
is that first album is fire
because it's your life story.
- Exactly.
- And now you got to go again
and you're like,
most people aren't good
at owning the truth of what just happened.
Why Jay-Z's last album
really worked for me.
- 444?
- Yeah 'cause what I
like that he's doing now
is he's not shying away from his truth.
It's just a different mature truth.
- Mmhmm, mmhmm, mmhmm.
Yeah it's tough to,
no you're so right
'cause with the first album
it's easy just to say
what you've experienced--
- And it's so fresh and
raw and real and so you
and then what?
- Right exactly.
- And it's why
so many people struggle.
And I keep trying to tell
people, tell me everything,
remember I think I told
this to Big K.R.I.T.,
I think that's exactly who I told it to,
I'm like just tell me everything
that's happened since.
Right?
It's the documenting versus creating.
It was easy for you to
make the first album.
You told me your dad hit you,
you told me that girl broke your heart,
you told me you were on drugs, you told me
and now there's this complex
where you kind of made it at some level
if you're on your second album
and you don't want to tell me the truth.
You don't want to tell me
you bought a stupid car
'cause you're insecure.
You don't want to tell me that
you're dating a pretty girl
than you could ever have gotten.
You don't want to tell me
'cause you don't think that's relatable.
Now you're trying to figure out
what I want to hear, got it?
- Yeah.
- Fucking makes so much sense, see?
- It does, yeah, it's crazy, yeah.
Rewiring shit that doesn't
need to be fucked with.
- This is why I love being a bad student.
This is why I dominate everything I do.
I don't want to know anything.
I don't want to know shit.
Even Boyd's like yo,
with you I had some context
but once in awhile, I'll meet someone,
I don't know anything,
I don't need to know anything.
I'm at my best where I know nothing.
- Damn.
Love that.
- It's why I like Q&A.
It's why I love doing this shit.
I don't want to know anything.
I'm just telling you
through my little lens
which is communication
and marketing and business
and people, I've got my things.
I can't tell you about arrangement,
I can't tell you about beats.
I've just come to realize what beats are.
I'm being dead serious.
I'm so lyriched out.
If I can't see what you're
saying in my head, I'm out.
There's no song that's every gotten me.
It's why I don't like things
like Who Let the Dogs Out.
I understand catchy shit
but I don't like it.
- So you're more lyrical
when it comes to listening?
- I'm a storyteller right by nature.
That's by Biggie destroyed
me, changed my life,
it was so, I talk to him
about this all the time.
You give me somebody who can,
it's what I like about T. Grizzly.
- Interesting.
- You agree?
- He's from Detroit.
- When he raps,
I see it in a way that I
don't see other rappers
which is why I think he's long term.
- He's a big dude so it's
kind of funny you said that.
- Makes sense though right?
- When he goes, I'm like
that's so clear to me.
I see other people who do a great job
but for some reason it
doesn't connect with me,
it's blurry a little bit
but with him, it's why
I gravitated so much,
I'm like man that's so clear.
I feel like I'm there.
I feel like I'm in his Bentley.
- That's the key to good songwriting.
- That make sense to you?
- And it's holy too,
yes it totally makes sense to me
Biggy's stories are just
ruined by people coming in.
- Yeah dude, I'm like laying in that room
with the fucking poster, I'm
like that's me, it's so real.
- He's from Detroit right, isn't he?
- Yes.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah he's great.
No but you're right,
that's the key to songwriting it's like--
- Oh actually, you know what's funny,
just to 'cause now we're fucking around,
like when he gives, like
I'm just going there,
when I know that I feel something,
when he gives shout out to his boys
that got caught in the
armed robbery with him
when he does that in a song,
if I can see the person,
even though I have no
idea what they look like,
if I can literally see them,
like whatever fucking visual
comes, I see a human in my head
then I know it's there
and a lot of times I don't see them.
I like it, it's interesting,
I'm like oh that's cool,
I'm like oh those are the
boys he got fucked up with,
but I can't see them.
- It's like on the surface.
- No, like Biggy's room
that he's laying in,
I actually have a dead
visual for right now,
every piece of it.
- That's wild.
- Like the poster's fucked up
and like the room's fucking
ghetto as shit, the lamp
and there's fucking Phillies
all laying around on the table
and he's got a tape deck.
I can draw it for you.
- Yeah, that's crazy.
- Yeah I think it is crazy.
That's how I synthesize.
- It's so interesting
to hear that
just on the other side of the table
as being a musician,
someone who digests the music.
You're right 'cause if you can,
if you can force your brain to think,
someone's words are making
you be that imaginative
in your own mind,
that means they're doing a great job.
- What they're really doing,
and this is why sports win,
this is why movies win,
we as humans need escapism.
The fuck are you binge
watching Netflix for?
You need a break from your real life
and the more you love your life,
the less you need escapism.
It's why I don't consume a lot of content.
It's why music really works for me
'cause it's passive
and I can do it when I travel, got it?
'Cause I love my life.
And when I was in school
and I hated my life
'cause I hated school,
I only needed escapism.
Got it?
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- So like this is why I'm so passionate
about getting people,
like I don't think people get it,
I'm like yo, give up Netflix
and FIFA and Fortnite
and listening to music for a little bit
and do something that lets
you get out of what you hate
so that you don't need that shit.
So then it's just you take
it when you can get it
but you don't need it.
Music, film, TV and video games
are literally as close to
drugs as you could imagine.
Escapism.
When you're really fucked up,
you've got to go somewhere
completely outer space,
you've got to really
fucking knock yourself out
but that's what's so powerful about music.
It's why teenagers love it.
It's why they're shit's
the most fucking angsty.
That transition.
And then that's what
rock'n'roll did for that group,
it's what hip hop does for this group.
There'll be something else that comes up.
- Interesting idea.
- I'll tell you why it's
an interesting idea.
What I'm trying to actually accomplish
'cause I know a little bit of your stuff,
I think when one understands
certain frameworks,
it makes them write differently.
When I got more thoughtful
about what the fuck was happening with me,
I got better, not worse.
I brought more to the audience, not less.
I didn't educate myself.
You know what happens?
I actually think it's a way,
I actually think what I just talked about
is the way to not become
a caricature of yourself.
It's the first time I've
ever said that out loud.
- I'm just curious, what
do you mean by that?
- I'm gonna explain.
What happens to so many people?
They do something, it works
and then even without realizing it,
they become that character, right?
Like this is what we all,
you like that one right?
You don't react to too
much, I'm excited when you,
it makes sense right?
And as you can imagine,
I've got a very high energy personality.
So I was super thinking
about it at one point.
I'm like am I now just playing Gary Vee
or is this actually, right?
Comedians do it, actors, like it's real.
So something in what I
just described to you
is if you're obsessed with
bringing value to the audience
and you understand it in the macro.
Like now I don't even think I'm alive.
I'm in some weird shit.
Now I'm like yo,
first of all, one of the great things
about having any talent,
like I don't actually think it's mine.
I fully think everything
I am is my parents
and my circumstance.
I don't know what else to say.
What the fuck did I do?
I didn't have sex at that moment.
I got lucky that I grew up with nothing
and had to fucking grind.
Everything I am is a circumstance
of shit that I didn't, right?
So when you actually go there,
all the accolades mean nothing
'cause you're happy
'cause you're passing it
on to shit you care about.
I care about America's opportunity
and I care about my parents.
I love it.
I'm like, yo, keep giving me compliments.
- [Tyler] We've got to
go in like 90 seconds.
- Okay.
It's like there
and then I'm just, now I'm like yo,
I'm in a weird place man.
I guess what's really fucking me up
is just getting those
emails and DMs of like,
I was gonna kill,
like I don't know how anybody on Earth
who gets any letter ever, back to Logic,
must've gotten a drillion,
getting one DM from one person
saying I was gonna take my life
and your content made me not
is a transformative thing that
happens to any human being
that's actually in touch
with their feelings.
It's heavy.
And then you're just on the mission.
Then it's like everything
else is like, what?
What the fuck am I ever gonna do
that's bigger than that?
- Really, yeah.
- Right?
Buy the Jets, it doesn't
mean shit, like fuck that.
Like a human was gonna die
and then watched a video
and decided not to.
I can't.
And I get, Tyler, just looking at you,
this is why the people closest
to me like me the most,
they see the truth, right?
- Yeah.
- That's fucking,
that's heavy too.
- And this is
what you have too
and this is what any artist that aspires,
whether it's behind the camera, writing.
You're one fucking sentence away
from changing everything.
You know what kind of power that is?
And now in music,
the fact that some 60
year old in an ivory tower
doesn't get to stop you,
they almost didn't let
Tupac have that song.
Thank God the right
executive was in that room.
You know what that song did for people?
- Mmhmm, it's crazy.
- Dude, you literally
live the rest of your life
with the ability of writing one sentence
that could change everything.
I literally feel that every
time I'm making content.
I'm like this,
that's what happens when you
get a little bit of a platform,
it means that for anybody.
Anybody can make their first
video and change the game
but you recognize when you
have a little bit of a platform
it's got a little bit
more of a chance, right?
- Right.
- Every day I feel that
sense of responsibility
like today's the day
I'm gonna make one video
that actually changes everything,
it's gonna get, I know it's gonna happen
and everyone's gonna be like,
in the macro, be like, who is this guy?
And the core group is gonna be like,
what do you mean who is this guy?
He's been around forever.
But like that's so exciting right?
- Yeah, it's crazy man.
- That's why I want people
to put out more music.
- Yeah.
- Because if you only
put out fucking 14 songs
every 18 months,
you're not gonna make it happen as likely
as if you're gonna fucking
put out 750 songs a year.
I mean it.
Like what are we doing here?
- Yeah seriously.
- Any way we can help.
- Thanks man.
This was awesome dude.
Just to pick your brain for two seconds.
- Just put shit out.
For us, we got lucky.
Now fucking squeeze the
fuck out of that luck.
- Yeah.
- Before we go, why don't
you say a little bit
about your upcoming album
that's dropping in a couple weeks.
- Yeah, yeah, it comes out February 15th.
It's called From Michigan With Love.
It's strictly on mental health
and just talk about everything
that I've gone through
like with anxiety and depression
and how it followed me from Michigan,
being from Detroit, to now where I am
and even though shit's
going really well now,
it's like it hasn't gone anywhere,
it's still there.
- Of course not.
It's there forever.
- And I think now more than ever,
this topic of mental
health is so prominent.
- Thank God, thank God.
We used to not talk about alcoholism.
We used to not talk about marital abuse.
Light, light, light solves everything.
That's what I love about the internet.
Oh the internet fucked this, no it didn't,
it's exposing us.
Light, light.
You know why we're dealing with sexism
and racism and mental illness?
Because the mainstream
media doesn't hide it.
It's the best.
It sucks,
sucks when you've got to
look at yourself for real
but it gets real, real
good on the back end.
When we're all old,
we'll remember this little era
where it was a little angsty
as the beginning of a good thing.
Everybody thinks it's the
beginning of a bad thing.
Pessimism, confused how people are.
We're still here.
- That's so true.
- 100% true.
Everybody thinks, oh shit.
This is the beginning of the good.
- 'Cause the shit's being
addressed for the first time.
- Correct.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Talk to the suppressed.
Women, minorities,
about what they think about now.
They joke.
They're like this has been,
what are you talking about?
It's the people that
weren't paying attention
or chose not to pay attention.
This is the best era.
It feels weird.
Any time you got to look
yourself in the mirror
and deal with shit you
don't want to deal with.
America had to deal with some shit.
But it's gonna be way better.
- That's a great note to end on.
Yo, pleasure man, thank you so much.
- Yeah of course.
- Can we get a quick photo?
- 100,000%.
Who's got the camera?
- This guy right here.
- Boyd, give me one for my story.
- [Boyd] Okay, ready, got it.
- Thanks, brother,
appreciate it.
- Thank you, guys.
- Yeah, take care, buddy.
- Hey guys.
Thank you so much for
watching my video on YouTube.
I wanted to jump in here at the end
because I'm working
on a ridiculously important project for me
and I have a funny feeling you can help.
If you drink wine at all
or know anybody that drinks wine at all,
please go to empathywines.com right now
and sign up for a subscription.
Whether it's a three pack,
whether it's a six pack
or whether it's a whole
case of each for the year,
if you drink 36 bottles of wine a year
or give away 36 bottles of wine a year,
please sign up for Club Empathy.
This project means the world to me.
I could really use your support.
(upbeat music)